- She's a teacher, a
community college professor,
a mamma, a grand mama, and oh, yep,
she just happens to be the
First Lady of the United States.
Let's welcome Dr. Jill Biden, everybody!
(audience clapping)
(piano music)
- Hi everybody!
- [Kelly] Hello, hello!
High five from afar!
- [Jill] Hi, how are you?
- [Kelly] You look beautiful!
- [Jill] Well so do you!
- I know, it's like we dressed
like we look like a beautiful
garden I feel like, yes.
And well have a seat.
- [Jill] Thanks!
- I'm pretty sure this
is the furthest interview
I've ever given so if I shout I'm sorry.
- [Jill] That's okay.
- We're keepin' it safe.
We're keepin' it safe.
How're you doin' today?
- I'm doin' great, how 'bout you?
- I'm so lucky and fortunate to be here.
I cannot say thank you enough.
- Yes, welcome to my
house, the people's house,
your house.
- [Kelly] I know,
it's crazy you live here, but you're,
you're also the spotlight singer today.
I actually did not know this song.
I was very-
- [Jill] Oh no kidding!
- I always get excited
when people pick songs
I didn't know before and
then I get to learn them.
So the original version, the
Young Bloods, I think, right?
- [Jill] That's exactly right.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
So you love this song?
- I love this song because you know
I think it's so perfect for today,
you know, because I think our
country has been so divided
and you know, now if we
could just come together
as a country and solve our differences.
And I first heard it, course this is why
you haven't heard it, I
heard it in the sixties.
So, you know, there was the Vietnam war
the civil rights movement.
People, it was a similar time
where people were divided and
and the Young Bloods came out
with this song and everybody
would be singing it, you know
everybody come together.
So, strong message.
- Yeah, it's a beautiful thing.
And I feel like it's one
of those things where I'm like,
Oh, this was a cool moment.
Then it's then I also get kind of sad.
Cause I'm like, wow, this
message is relevant again.
Like I kind of get really sad
about that sometimes
too, but it's, it's nice.
I think that's why I love
being a part of music so much
because we're able to
create something that even
if you're from different walks
of life, you can, you know
come together and love a song together
and sing a song together.
- Well I could listen
to your voice all day.
- [Kelly] Oh, well, thank you.
I've had about four and
a half hours of sleep.
So you got my raspy Janis Joplin version.
- See, Janis Joplin.
She was from my era as well.
- [Kelly] I love Janis Joplin.
I'm Texan, I think you come
out of the womb loving her.
Well, you've said, I, I read your book.
I love "Where the Light Enters"
what a great quote that came from too.
- [Jill] Thank you.
- Yeah. It was really, really great.
And it- and it's something honestly,
separate from this question
to aspire to family-wise, um.
I found that inspiring.
So thank you for that.
And, and also you said that you-
you're like an introvert
married to an extrovert,
um, but you're pretty strong and fearless
because I did see something
where you were sticking
up for president Biden
and like the Philly girl came out of you.
- [Jill] It did, yeah.
- Yeah. Which I love, cause I-
Texas girls are just like
this photo by the way.
- [Jill] Oh, good.
- [Kelly] Yes, yes.
- Yeah. Well, we protect
the people we love. Right?
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
And how often does she come out?
- Um, probably, hm,
every once in a while.
I mean, hopefully things like this
won't happen again and
now we have, you know
the secret service to protect Joe, but uh,
you know, I think being from Philly it's.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I love that part of my growing up.
And I think the people from
Philadelphia are strong
and tough and- uh.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's just a part of who I am.
I was actually just upstairs
watching the Villanova game.
So, you know, it never quite leaves me.
- Oh, so you're a serious
sports ball lover.
All right.
I see this, I see this, but, um.
Twitter blew up and I always
think it's funny when you do
something so important, like good job.
So prestigious as yourself
and, and even your husband.
Twitter seems to blow up over the, like,
the most silly things.
And I noticed you are a scrunchie
and like everybody lost their mind.
And I was like, I think we
all wear scrunchies, but yeah.
So you are, are you usually
this much of a fashionista
with your scrunchies.
- [Jill] Well, you know,
my daughter called me right
after I left that shop
and said, you know, mom
everybody's talking about the scrunchie.
I said, what scrunchie?
I didn't know what she was talking about.
I still don't know and understand it.
- [Kelly] I love it.
Well, I'm just saying if you're gonna
start bringing back scrunchies,
just throw in the banana clips as well
because I was a huge banana clip fan.
I was like, look, it all
goes up and look styled.
It's like a Mohawk.